this became the new normal in Hong Kong
in 2019 almost daily violence between
masked protesters and police the spark
that eventually set the streets and
emotions on fire was a decision to
ignore the outcry of millions of people
and push through a controversial
extradition bill which would have
allowed any suspect in the city to be
tried in the courts of mainland China
and the people just went nuts people
thought if we don't fight now this is
our last fight and if we don't fight now
we'll have no chance and we're fighting
quarry Mo was one of the legislators who
marched with hundreds of thousands to
protest against the bill Hong Kong's
chief executives said the bill was
needed to extradite a Hong Kong murder
suspect from Taiwan but people feared it
not only put them at the mercy of
China's Communist Party controlled legal
system but would also allow Beijing to
seize anyone who set foot in the city
the unrest continued into July and then
the protesters raced the stakes
aljazeera was one of the first
international networks to broadcast
massed young people storming the Hong
Kong government headquarters in an
attempt to disrupt any more meetings by
the legislature the bill is dead and
finally two months later chief executive
Carrie Lam conceded and withdrew the
bill but the unrest continued as the
movement went on the focus changed to
police brutality and that kind of like
making people think that Hong Kong is
becoming more like a authoritarian
regime and that brings more people out
as a result Kelvin Lam was voted into
office in historic district council
elections in November
nearly half of Hong Kong's 7 million
people went to the polls giving the
city's pro-democracy camp and opposition
parties control of a political body for
the first time Hong Kong will not be the
same again because the anger or the
discontent of the other side he will
still be kind of embedded in people's
minds it has been mostly quiet since its
of the year there are still sporadic
protests but instead of thousands on the
streets it's now hundreds or dozens and
police are much quicker to use crowd
control measures and make arrests but
many fear this could just be the calm
before the storm there is so much hatred
between the protesters and the
experiment Hong Kong can never be really
government again the protesters here say
the government hasn't made any attempt
to address their concerns
instead it's taking a tougher stance
against dissent making people fear that
it's just a matter of time before scenes
like this once again take over the
streets the big apollon al Jazeera Hong
Kong